[Music]
olive oil wine cheese and much more
the eu is known for its quality
agriculture and delicious produce
for decades the bloc has supported and
financed the agricultural sector
so how was this flagship eu policy born
it all began in 1962 when european
leaders created the common agricultural
policy or cap
the goal was to ensure plentiful and
affordable food for europeans while
making sure farmers enjoyed fair living
standards
as a result food production boomed in
some areas a little too much in 1984
quotas were put in place to help bring
agricultural production closer to market
needs to avoid overproduction and waste
this applied to products like milk
in 1992 farmers became the direct
recipients of eu funds instead of the
market and to make it more
environmentally friendly farmers were
also encouraged to play a bigger role in
preserving ecosystems
further improvements came in 2003 when
the eu proposed funds for farmers who
ensured food safety and applied high
environmental and animal welfare
standards
the importance of reducing greenhouse
emissions was also highlighted
with the 2009 lisbon treaty the european
parliament gained new legislative powers
including in the agricultural sector
and in 2013 parliament used those new
powers to approve the updated cap
the eu wanted greener and fairer farming
this meant diversifying crops and
maintaining a rich landscape but also a
fairer distribution of support to eu
farms
europe
in 2019 meps began work on the revamped
cap proposal from the commission it aims
to encourage an agricultural sector that
supports farmers ensures sustainable
food and
the new cap will fully integrate eu
environmental and climate laws in a
whole host of ways including supporting
organic and small-scale farming
[Music]
you